[Music]  change  i see it in everything  i see it in a boy rocked by tragedy  transform his pain and defy reality  i see it in the warrior who must choose  between their new life  and the annihilation of their home  i see it in a girl tortured by revenge  embrace hope when love awakens her heart  i see it in me a boy born  under a bad woman turn his tail  into a legend  change is relentless  but that does not mean it cannot be  beautiful  take comfort  nothing lasts forever  you must adapt  surrender  and embrace your true nature  know that you are not alone  change comes for us all  but this chaos has purpose  all of us thrown together  so the flame can burn its brightest  change fight it  and fall  accept it and rise above  [Music]